on this week's show how to use the
equity in your home to grow a property
portfolio in the news is it possible to
reap the rewards of property without
taking any risks and William answering
all your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
hi almost leads I'm Alistair Cunningham
and welcome to this week's property
investors podcast we've got a fantastic
show coming up I think we absolutely
have we're gonna be talking about how
you can use your current home to buy
lots of other properties and grow your
portfolio which is always very very
excited so question it comes up lots at
crash course as a particular people are
always saying I've got equity in the
house how can we release that and how
can we air you you put that to good use
exactly a lot of the time it's funny
when we the deal firing extravaganza and
we talk about how much money people have
got and how they can be creative a lot
of people forget that they've got money
in their own home that they could put to
good use so yeah it's gonna be an
interesting one anyway have you had a
good week yes we have had a very busy
week again so what did it consist of is
this it feels like ages ago but it was
actually a few days glass it's just been
very busy but I'm thirsty I was out
looking at new crash course venues so
we're looking for a bigger venue nice as
the crash course ever grows ever every
every week every month we need to find
bigger and bigger venues and more nicer
venues so we're now looking at them I
found quite a few nice venues in central
London beautiful very good and then what
happened on Monday on Monday yeah Monday
we went to meet the wolf the wolf they
done they're done and it Walker doesn't
it it's not but um
[Music]
[Music]
do you know that that's not actually
true yeah Jordan broke the news to us
that that when the first things he said
on state where he come onstage was he
was funny watching us all do that mm-hmm
but he said it's actually it was a
ritual Matthew McConaughy had who played
the broker wasn't it there his his men
talk yeah and he used he does that
apparently before filming to settle
himself down he was doing it off set and
the director went we need this and that
is brilliant he'd that movie but he's
such an interesting character now
there's no denying what he done was
wrong but he's definitely sort of seen
it seen the light and sort himself out
yeah and he's you know promotes very
ethical selling and he's a very very
nice guy and he's do you know what I
loved about him is he's obviously a
celebrity he's obviously like made made
lots and lots of money and he's very
famous throughout the world but he was
come and sit in chat with us like we are
sites right here no I wouldn't he yeah
when it was like when we're having like
opportunities he was he was happily
taking opportunity for photographing
sit and chat with you for a couple of
minutes and just talk about what he'd
been up to and Alistair said to him you
should actually be dead right now
well we had an open answer question and
answer session and everyone was asking
him like about property really not
probably but investments and how to know
who cares about that when you talk about
drugs
and I I literally said I'm sorry Jordan
I'm gonna make this a bit personal and I
said listen man after your life so you
should you shouldn't be here you should
be dead and he agreed and he laughed it
off it was it was quite funny I've got
it on video
I said undeniably like he should be dead
the amount of stuff he snorted and and
done everything and just his lifestyle
mean he crashed a helicopter he sunk our
yacht and he wore a lab just everything
and he shouldn't be here but and I just
asked him what his lowest point was when
it was he realized there actually shared
I need to change and then sorta so it
was actually in the film wasn't in the
film it was it was the scene if you've
seen the wolf of Wall Street if you
haven't watched the bit where he tried
to break out with his daughter and drove
through the Gary
that was I thought that might have been
like this for the film but not that that
was a genuine scene it definitely
happened very interesting guy what did
you like about them so I just I'll just
like he's charisma he's just very kind
of infectious kind of he's got that
ability any - yeah no he was it was
amazing so yes it's been a good a good
really good week right so equity pulling
equity out at the house yeah
okay so first of all how would someone
know if they had equity in their house
or not and well you know how much your
mortgages so speak to your mortgage
lender and find out what your balance is
and then get a valuation done in the
property and how much someone go about
having a valuation done sauce
ring on a state agent and say you're
looking to sell your house get them to
come out and value it or you could
appoint a Rick surveyor might cost you a
few hundred pounds or I speak to a
mortgage broker and just say the easiest
way you're thinking of Riva am
remortgaging your property and they'll
say in there Rick so via route to do the
valuation and then they'll give you a
figure of what they think is worth and
then they'll give a figure of what you
can withdraw from that property
typically it would be no more than
eighty percent I would have thought and
depending on the but you can't get 90
percent on Paris no mortgages but if
they know you're going to be using it to
invest in property the tip we don't go
above eighty percent and even there they
are a bit rarer so it's more like a
seventy five percent
yeah there is people do to 80 percent
and if you've good then you just it's
just it's not hard
no so basically just speak to a broker
yeah and you just say hey I'm thinking
of remortgage in my house can you ever
look at it for me though and that
basically they walk you through all the
steps don't they yeah it's very simple
and a remortgage is generally quicker
than our mortgage because you've already
got proven history you've already
everything's in place and if you keep it
with the same lender it's even quicker
so I know somebody got a remortgaging
like two and a half weeks mmm but then I
know people it takes months so but it's
also good if you're at the end of your
soft fixed term where your interest rate
it's good to shop around and get cheaper
interest rates if you're on a repayment
mortgage yeah it's always good so you've
got a lot of properties
looking at every now and again yeah have
you quit looking ok how much they got up
can I pull some money out can I invest
that money cuz it's funny we talked
about obviously return on investment a
lot we don't really normally look at the
the we're looking at cashflow mainly we
don't really look at the capital
appreciation and you can earn a lot of
money if you've got a few properties a
lot a lot of money from capital
appreciation so like for instance my
property in Northampton when we moved
there because of my I couldn't prove my
financial accounts because one my but my
the business was less than a year old so
didn't have a full year accounts and I
had to be a slightly higher interest
rate which was fine it was enough long
with that but as soon as we got to the
end of the two years I refinanced that
and I'm I saved like three hundred pound
a month on my mortgage and we still
pulled some money out so like you got a
look at you gotta weigh the odds up if
you can if you if you've got a ableton
your property and you can refinance it
let's just say it puts your mortgage
payments up because typically it will
let's just say picture mortgage payments
up by having a three hundred pound a
month but then you can pull out 30 grand
you can invest that 30 grand into
another property which will give you
that 300 pound X for a month so your and
some and some yeah so at the minute
let's just say you break even but now
you have another asset that's increasing
in value so then in two years time you
can do that with that asset and then
before you know you've got all these
assets they're all increasing in value
and I would far rather have assets than
the cash because what what a lot of
people tend to do is they tend to
remortgage spend it spend it
so that and it was a thing wasn't it and
the the naughties two thousand that
people were refinancing every couple of
years just to pay off the debt so they
were the crew they over a period of a
couple of years then he would refinance
to pay that day off and anybody start
again and that seems like stupid just
live within your means it does it seemed
after night and then they were used it
for holidays and yeah I think if you use
it in one way is stupid but at least
they're paying off their debt because
they you are earning capital
appreciation aren't you so yeah it's not
smartest use of the
the money but it they're still they're
still making the most of the fact that
there they've got a property that's
going to pay value of course they are
yeah but they'd be better to use that
equity wisely as opposed to non wisely
if if that's a word that can we have
that as a quote because less they're
cutting them you'd be better off using
your equity wisely rather unwisely no
non wisely non one unwisely no we better
to use your equity wisely rather than on
what if that's gonna be like a Winston
Churchill Court Court in hundred years I
else they're coming very much you
directly wisely not unwisely are not non
wise and the only does it not quite make
sense it's not even a word it's also
like the stupidest listen just use your
equity properly drackett is one of those
sayings where sounds like a Ricky
Gervais scene if someone like Robert
Kiyosaki said it oh yeah yeah they'd be
like inspired me they're just idiot
someone would say some pompous saying do
you know T Harv Eker it got his got his
book you you were there actually but
I'll just say is quite funny way T
Harvick had got his book to the New York
Times number one bestseller yeah and he
was saying do you how hard it is to get
your book to the number one New York you
know number one best New Times
bestseller when your name is just TR
Becker like it's almost impossible your
book has got to be flippin amazing
because you're a nobody
yeah ish you know obviously we we you've
some of you were probably but in
comparison to you know but it is that if
you're Oprah Winfrey
you don't have to do anything and it's
gonna be New York Times best sir you
could literally release a book the pages
were completely blank and people be
looking at it going wow that's so deep
she's she's she's proving that the
purpose of life is nothing or something
you know yeah so unfortunately my friend
you are not at the level quite I know
that I know where you can say you better
to be wise than non wise and people of
all deep maybe they are if you think
it's deep
just comment below deep if you think
it's full of hot I just put a hot spell
than what you normally say so that's
good I'm good I'm good with that
let's see how many diesel have you have
you refinance any properties I have cool
how often every couple years have three
years four years the it depends I
haven't haven't refinanced a property
more than once
okay I do think is you've got be careful
not to not to we're talking this in the
last show but leverage not to be over
leveraged so I would only refinance if
you've got a use for that money or if
it's gonna save your money on like
interest rates and things that if you're
on a repayment but I wouldn't do it just
for the sake of doing it and you've got
have a plan for that money but it's
definitely a great way to grow a
property business yeah yeah using none
of your money essentially because it's
just yeah but it's not cash in the bank
is it no it's money in an asset that
you're releasing to create another asset
yeah and I think that that that is the
beauty of it takes time but that's the
beauty of property investing I think you
literally you don't need to have loads
as long you get started it goes it and
it's all about momentum isn't it it's
just like it'll slowly as you if you
have one and you remortgaging again over
one and if five years later even always
bow for them yeah and buyer number two
and that it's just going bigger and
bigger and bigger and it just it just
takes time it takes time but the beauty
that's why we always say get started now
yeah the sooner you get started the
sooner that it starts didn't saw it
interrupt you and cut you off there
that's okay someone moaned about you
doing that swear yeah I said I did to
you as well in fairness they were like
you both of you just cut each other off
continually do it I don't I don't agree
well that's fine let's say let's not
look out for it okay go on you say your
point okay so I've kind of forgotten
that's cuz you cut me off no it's
because you had that waffle about you
cut me off then I waffled about me
cutting you off
you met you I've lost it now you've got
just lost it what we even talking about
yeah yeah didn't Samuel say good job
Nick said a few weeks ago it was either
forgotten about the time isn't like
people morning about oh yeah it's too
good for it was
was back then those were the days yet
laws were the days it was back then that
the times were good but in 20 years
the in 20 years time the kids are 20
like then we'll be seeing all of those
were the days for now yeah I look back
at my grandparents that saw that they
bought a house for like a grand and I'm
like what my friend yeah 20 cash just
have it mind you they are in Detroit
that's true and in Philadelphia yeah
maybe we should just go somewhere like
horrible in America by like a whole
street mmm
gate it and turn it into a private gated
hood yes can still be a hood but I have
it gazes hood do it up the houses were
quite nice houses were big there's a big
in America like a three-bed up like to a
three-bed sort of our two floor house
it's the big rooms huge space we could
provide we could probably buy the whole
of Detroit maybe not well yeah I bet
this villages we could buy and starve it
there's like I bet there's areas there
probably is he could buy the nectar when
I was in America with Samuel we were
like in places like him like back into
Philadelphia New Jersey like place one
place I'm think it was Camden you can
buy a house for 16 grand 16 K that's
tall those as well it's making pounds I
think
what's that twelve twelve twelve
thousand pounds I might buy a house
would you live there no but you could
buy a house for 12 grand and yeah but
again people say in all time it was good
back in the days you just got doing
you've got to do it now forget back in
the days forget next month
just do it just just just whatever you
do and just do it now and stop worrying
about war it was like 10 years ago or
what it might be like in 10 years time
because but I'm 10 years later time come
new Blake mmm should have done that
because back in ten years ago it was
good but just just get involved well the
only moment that you ever have is now
yep this is it present so what we've
been doing a lot we've been doing a lot
of them like main stuff recently and it
talks a lot about being just being
present and being in
the present and not worrying about what
happens in future or in the past
so yeah just be present and just deal
with whatever you're dealing with no
yeah maybe that can be my skin just deal
with whatever you're dealing with no
that's a better saying this is rather
the it's best got to be non wise right
okay so if you were a view so basically
cut a long story short on on equity
check by just speaking to a mortgage
broker just we hang up and say this is
the house will I be able to remortgage
it I've done that loads and they're just
gone no okay I bought the house for this
it's like five years that first house I
took guy that I always seem to get asked
about there was my first house of the
know white but I was trying to
remortgage that for years about every
year would ring them up and go is he
good up yet and they'd be like no has he
got over yet
no it just and then it's actually got a
bit down also are depressing
spawning on and then eventually
eventually it went up about 25 at 25
grand but it was like because I know
we've mean me and least I've got like
are a lot of equity in our house and
because it's gone up considerably in the
last sort of two to five years and we've
we refinanced it after we moved in to
get a better rate but we didn't take any
money out just waitin to a better rate
but I know we've got a chunk of it in
there yeah yeah it's you wonder though
don't you I water is Lisa that's not
King it's Lisa it's not King just cuz
it's our family home but you've got I
just can you wave to get any wife that's
probably easier so when we get when she
kicks me out we can sail it she never
watches this show you can say what you
want no I wouldn't know I don't know em
because it's my wife's family home [ __ ]
one customer Mitchell wife sorry it was
it passed and my family on our family
home she does realize by the way just so
you're all aware once you remortgage a
property it's still your family home so
yeah yeah
oh did you know what easy to do now you
win her over
okay - oh hey listen so this is good
tips for if you've got a partner if your
if your partner a mortgage it is they
don't be mortgage because of the they
may feel a little bit risky or something
uh you say she said look we're gonna
remortgage the house how much you better
pull out that i roughly mmm six figures
okay she said look I'm gonna vestment in
property which will create more money
for us but I'm also gonna buy you a
holiday home in Spain okay yeah she
would go for that
suddenly the family home thing not so
much that's true you can rent it out
yeah throughout the year towards daily
Weis many I think about what you can do
with the money no I know that baekje
might be I'll buy you a liver Tom
Hamburg
yeah Deal or No Deal yeah absolutely
in fairness my lease is all up for the
wrists but we've just not needed to
we've not needed to because we've just
rub it in now yeah I got six figures
don't need it no it's not that it's not
either no is that no it's not it's just
we've not had I need we've not had a
proper property anyway we've not had a
deal come up that we've not been able to
finance it's only so we've not needed to
cuz I so do not mean it's not alright
it's now time for this
[Music]
so in the news this week another article
from The Guardian
oh it's been popular last few weeks so
this is called ethical money property is
this an ethical alternative to
buy-to-let well number one I don't even
have to read the article [ __ ]
that to me sounds like it's suggesting
buy-to-let it's unethical mm-hmm she's
already got my back up a little bit but
whatever also its media isn't it so it
describes an ethical turnit of two by
two that aimed at those who basically if
you want to invest in property but you
think being a landlord is greedy yeah
I'm bad but you still invest in probably
make a bit of money and you don't want
any of the risks to go with you no I'm
happy to kick out a tenant or voids you
want any risks
you can lend your money to these guys
it's called reap it stands for real
estate annuity plan okay and it allows
lemon to the social enterprise and what
they do is they provide affordable
rented homes with people in housing
needs including those at risk of
homelessness okay and as an investor you
get three percent Interest a year but
it's you know safe it's totally safe
yeah it's not brilliant but it's not bad
so you haven't got any of the
responsibilities or inconvenience of
being allowed and also just fine
Tarrance check her references do you
have broken boiler I'm sorry I just I
can't get on with this man three percent
I said that's that's rubbish why would
anyone do that well so you put a hundred
grand into it to make three grand a yeah
absolutely ridiculous if you had a
million yeah how much was make then
three percent thirty-five thousand US
average salary average you've got you've
got to risk a million to make very grand
you put no answer again right would you
do it
what'd I do yeah we'd use if we do put a
million pound of your cash into that
I'll tomato and yeah yeah no no I cannot
see anybody I'm excited about that but
it's it's like it listen it's some the
higher the risk the greater the reward
with this there's very little risk there
is risk of course there's risk there's
very little there's risk you're giving
your money to somebody else
what's that cut what that that born what
that cover it that whatever who is a
company so it's our so how is it
governed what if they will bankrupt what
if the massive risk you're giving you
you're putting your money in somebody
else's hands to to invest for you so it
is it's more risky than investment
improperly yourself
I know it's hassle-free but no I think
that's just a way and then the earth is
a new space is it's a new space whoever
wrote that article in The Guardian just
like find something better to write
about man it's a who it is it's not real
cajones you see they even got a podcast
I don't care but I just think it's it's
um I think it's a bit are you stupid
no stupid mean there's a high risk high
reward this is very little risk in fence
also very little reward oh is it better
than leaving the money in the bank
yes and you know we're not dissing now
no no I'm sorry okay saying is good if
you're away if you're like just if
you're just sitting on millions and
millions of pounds you just one hour in
a little bit then find do that but if
you if you had just not just not for me
three million in the bank
yeah so how long has your money got me
tied up in it law so that's the thing
it's not a thing and but we've we've
discussed on this show before
very early on Nick maybe you can find
that episode and stick a link somewhere
and those are a company where you could
put money into it you get into a
guarantee in 7% I'm sure there was it
was via the dimension that and his own
and it was some sort of fun that you
could put the money into we discussed
that Mary Ann is more tempting you must
do anything sweet she's boring into it's
not even like it's a threesome
it's very low it's like practically an
inflation and what sort of stuff it's
just it's not worth it no although
probably oh yeah no it's really nice
it's really it's really not but you just
move on if you if you if you are very
scared about investing in property you
might find do you know what it does do
it highlights how good probably less
absolutely so you know for all you're
watching this I'm sure you want to
invest in property don't do reap no I
wouldn't you know it's a waste of time
just yeah property and make twenty
percent of capital appreciation 40
percent 50 percent 100 percent that
would be a lot just in property yeah
anyway it's now time for questions and
answers
[Music]
okay so first question I like this
question it's about cars a hmm my new
cars getting order today is it today
hopefully just waiting for the phone
call back to say that they've got it and
because it's in stock you going caiman
aren't you yeah great caiman yeah just
to ruin it for anyone what you know so
that he can't he can't show it off and
go hey look at the oh yeah we now it's
great caiman with black wheels
well good black wheels anyway yeah
what's the cheapest way to finance a car
apart from buying for cash in your
opinion why would you buy for cash I
don't understand well he's betting
doesn't want to buy for cash it he wants
to finance it how would he eat I think
he was scared we would go to fight for
cash no now we wouldn't heart from I'm
sorry how would it affect your best get
a mortgage in the future well okay so
obviously car finance will pee on your
credit check okay port that's on that
yeah oh hi
okay okay apparently a Charlotte watches
this yeah Charlotte one of the Academy
members right she's always she picked
that up you know winner when I say okay
it sounds like Hawkeye okay and then I
spoke onstage and she was in audience
and she started laughing and it picked
me right off when I said okay
okay okay okay go ahead right okay so
back to our finance okay time for the
okay okay okay okay buy the car - right
and obviously when you have any
financing name it'll appear in your
credit report that will be seen by the
the lenders when they do a credit search
I don't speak to a mortgage broker as
long as you've got my car phone no no
about affecting his mortgage ability so
speak to a broker I mean it really
affects it I don't think it affects it
as long as you're up to date if you're
in arrears and obvious it's gonna affect
it but keep up to date as long as you're
not over leveraged on anything like then
you'll be fine John okay the best way
yeah in my opinion - the cheapest way
any way that we ask cheapest yeah the
cheapest way is to lease
yeah and the best website I have found
now I haven't actually used his website
but I have recommended to other people
who have so my sister was used it my mom
has used it for example but the best
website is a website called leasing calm
and they're based on comparison website
and they just seem to have cheaper deals
than anywhere else I can find
yeah I think I think so so I got
suckered in - right so what what I
actually did was I went on leasing calm
my sister recommended to my sister my
mom and everything then when I wanted a
car I went to the garage and while I was
at the garage
I got sold on the idea ah so you went in
and you went I'm not gonna buy a car and
the salesman come along you okay I went
in and I was like I'm a test drive and
then once I think oh you're one of them
you're using them to taste Drive and
then you're gonna say I'll thank so much
and then good order online yeah that's
exactly what I was doing that was my
plan but what actually happened is and I
even said that to them I was up front I
was like listen I'm probably not gonna
buy because I think I can get cheaper
online yeah I was totally up front and
he but he said to me yeah you're right
it is a bit cheaper online of this and
I'm hey if you need me you can bring the
car back in and we'll order it and I
know looks at it I was like yeah it's
only about fifty quid a month more and I
get to get it now and that's why so I
got suckered and then I was sitting back
and I was like man that's 50 it's over
for years fifty quid a month
I'm I'm I'm not I have literally just
agreed to pay fifty times twelve times
for two and a half grand to order it off
this guy now and it kind of peed me off
I did it again back in when I go back in
at the end of the agreement God listen
guys it may be okay to do it once but
like when you don't let for a few
mistakes and you go back and you're like
I'm just tell me no it's not I actually
don't I actually I'm winding you up
I actually think you've done the right
thing because one you're keeping the guy
you're supporting a local business which
is always good it's not always about
saving a couple of Quitman it's not you
know you've got the cheapest way you can
do it
leasing calm there you go right okay so
next question is from Gabriel Cheung on
the YouTube channel so do you think it's
better to have a separate SPV to hold
each investment property or to use one
SPV to hold all investment properties is
there a mortgage impact I personally
have all my properties in one SPV I know
there's people have individual companies
set up for each each property are you'd
have to speak a mortgage broker with
regards to that I don't speak your
accountant most property tax accounts
and just say look what this is one about
yeah you just tell me the best way of
doing it yeah another question from KN
TX on YouTube how do I get on the
eviction do you guys want a young
American already successful from the
insurance industry schooling some
British in their own pond with home
field advantage not to mention you're
pretty easy on the eyes
mmm that all depends my friend school in
the British in in there and the problem
is buddy the problem is like see when
you work with us we rely on a little
thing called being humble yeah come on
that's far me like a bit confidence is
if we even know if it's a boy or girl me
know however if it's a young lady you
that it just a young American this is
young American so if there's a young
American lady soon as a picture we'll
have a look I think it sounds a guy I
think girls aren't so am I like if we do
it we I mean this this eviction its he's
too late it's already Aptus already done
but I put next time we'll advertise no I
like I don't know
we'll know I don't know I think it's for
Yuki only not UK only I'd love to see an
American had a members-only isn't it
join the Academy during the Academy and
then we will get you in yeah awesome
right next question
let me find one all right here you go
interesting question I haven't actually
thought this quick I've just quickly
scammed it now I don't know the answer
off top of my head but you should see if
you do so hello response there are there
any property any strategies rights
property investing a beer investments
JVs flippin etc because they all seem to
involve interest payments are there any
but do not involve interest payments
that is to say not paying all receiving
any interest I'm assume and this is from
calendar Hara so hey Callen thanks the
question Kalyn was it can Kalyn I'm
assuming it's a religious thing yeah I
mean I I deal with a lot of investors
and yeah so really I think it's mean
their religious thing they don't like
paying interest or the interest rent to
rent this knowing there's no rain
threatening because you're paying a rent
yeah they know in terrestrial receiving
a set fee so there'd be no interest on
there's lots of companies out there
friends since that do like Muslim
mortgages and do religious mortgages and
non-interest bearing and so there is a
lot of a lot of help out there for just
google it there's a how does that work I
I don't know I don't know the exactly
that I think they have a charge at the
front but you don't have to pee and I
don't know I honestly don't know so I
would I would Google like know an
interest-bearing mortgages I know I've
got several sort of Muslim investors
that they use them quite quite em
successfully so I think the risk there
is our business out there for it and
there is our I call for a massive call
for it so awesome awesome stuff so if
there any that just don't use interest
like
so for example of the rent to rent can
you think of anything that just doesn't
if you if you're using a lease option
for instance if you get a secure lease
option in the property you're just
paying out among the least people
there's no interest on that though
obviously when it comes to buying it you
may have to pay interest because you
need a mortgage yeah you'd need to buy
it for cash yeah but for cash yeah or
get this mortgage talked about but yeah
have a look have a look at we are one
more question on here probably and I'll
go on age okay so sue bore me great sure
thanks man if you had three hundred
thousand pound to invest what would you
do with the money he's seventeen year
old made his money from the gas and oil
markets and three hundred K eighteen
year old just get it get investment
property man get putting some of that
money into deposits get buying some
houses awesome right I've got to but one
of them we've already answered kind of
hi guys CJ Bri hi guys great show can
you run through the refinancing process
yes we can rewind the episode isn't do
it again awesome last question this is
from Barlow so look he said borrow
borrow is fine I remember he commented
but but on YouTube but Barlow is his
preferred he's asked a few questions
that have split the sky several times he
wants to join the Academy someone
awesome man awesome so Barlow
hi guys hopefully this one will be a
challenging one after we've made so much
effort on your name and then you give us
a tough question what was initially we
just make isn't now god seller has put a
seller has put on the market owned by
him old bakery which is a commercial /
residential property after discussions
he also admitted the next door property
which also his would be saleable there
was no plan permission in place yet for
any development the property is not
mortgageable though residential mortgage
the property is not mortgageable through
residential mortgage but commercial will
be an option for the or baking property
what would be your list of actions to
acquire both buildings the investor from
London is ready to put the money down
the catch agency clan the owner will not
be waiting for completion for completing
the purchase until we get the plan
in place slightly finished
yeah that's such a long question
basically he wants to buy a bakery and
he can't get normally and then he's got
a commercial mortgage yeah
but the lender won't agree to anything
until he's got planning permission but
that just seems backwards why would why
would you why would that why would the
why would the owner care if they are
planning I don't know but can you make
that question a little bit more direct
we don't really know what you want
what's the what what's the outcome to be
what I would do Bart is batlló is I
would go and speak to a mortgage broker
motional always broke explain the
situation to them see what see what the
situation is you can find someone like
readers caught financial for example
they will look at both commercial and
residential so get them to go and have a
look at it see what they could do I
don't know what about the scene it seems
that the vendors been awkward seeing
you're not AB you know we're not going
to do anything until you've got planning
that approved maybe maybe that's because
they've somebody else has previously
said the buyer and then pulled out a
later stage because they couldn't get
planning maybe so it might be that might
be wise so you need to ask the vendor
what they really want and just go speak
to a mortgage broker find out if cephas
even guess where the works for us were
my first step and then if come back to
us next week once you've done that if
there's any further questions yeah man
great awesome listen thank you ever so
much for watching the show hope you
enjoyed it do not forget we'll be back
next Saturday at 7 p.m. do not get too
chewed and hit subscribe and we will see
you next week see you there guys
[Music]
[Applause]